- Cette pépinière de la Rive-Sud
roule à plein régime depuis
trois semaines déjà.
LUCIE CHARBONNEAU, employée,
Les Serres Dauphinais St-Hubert
- Ça a commencé dès le 30 avril.
Ça ne démord pas. Déjà,
il y a des tablettes vides.
- Chaque jour, le centre de
jardinage accueille en moyenne
1500 clients.
- Ça paraît qu'on est
en pandémie. Les gens
ont le goût de jardiner,
et avec raison.
- C'est relaxant, puis même
si on ne sort pas à l'extérieur,
bien, on est chez soi
et on se sent un petit peu
en vacances.
- L'an dernier, près
de 3 millions de familles
au Québec ont jardiné,
une hausse de 20 % par rapport
à l'année précédente.
C'est selon un sondage mené
par Québec Vert et la Fédération
interdisciplinaire de
l'horticulture ornementale
du Québec. Et tout indique
que la tendance se maintient.
- La section du basilic,
c'est ici.
- Les meilleures ventes :
les produits de potager,
les fines herbes, tomates,
concombres. L'engouement
pour le jardinage amène son lot
de défis pour les pépinières.
Le plus grand : la difficulté
de recruter du personnel
pour répondre à la demande.
VÉRONIQUE DAUPHINAIS, coproprié.
Les Serres Dauphinais St-Hubert
- Cette année, j'en aurais pris
15 à 20 employés de plus à temps
plein, pour la période de vente.
- Pour la prochaine saison,
elle prévoit embaucher davantage
de travailleurs étrangers
pour éviter de se retrouver
dans la même situation.
- L'échalote française
et des radis.
- L'horticulteur Bertrand Dumont
est dans le domaine depuis
une quarantaine d'années.
BERTRAND DUMONT
horticulteur et baladodiffuseur
- C'est une année très
compliquée pour les centres
de jardin, les jardineries,
les producteurs. Mais à côté
de ça, c'est une année qui va
être extrêmement intéressante
au point de vue financier parce
que ça va être une année record.
Normalement, la saison se finit
aux alentours fin juin.
Moi, ce que j'anticipe,
c'est qu'on va finir
peut-être au 10 juin.
- Et la grande question
maintenant : avec un retour
vers la vie un peu plus normale,
est-ce que cet engouement
pour le jardinage va perdurer
l'été prochain? Difficile